[Musique]
non
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois trois sacres et
contestataire de notre époque chacun
évidemment à sa manière le premier c'est
françois bégaudeau dont la nouvelle
pièce piscine sera créée le 21 janvier à
la comédie de colmar dans une mise en
scène de mathieu crucia ni le deuxième
c'est victor du groupe victor and the
fighters qui sort un premier album
blackout et sera en concert à la belle
maison à bagnolet samedi prochain le 18
janvier et le troisième enfin c'est pas
comme si elle ment pour son nouveau
livre tu m'as donné de la crasse et j'en
ai fait de l'or chez masse aux éditions
mais commençons tout de suite par notre
époque qu'est ce qui la caractérise
alors cette époque que vous trouvez
pourris tous les trois chacun à sa
manière
voici vos réponses en images on commence
par votre image avoue d'ailleurs pacôme
thiellement mais c'est un dessin dessins
de gb lundi 5 gb mais continue et
conceptuelle avec la présente émission
stérile mgb il est mort depuis déjà un
moment certaines vieilles images mais là
beaucoup circulé sur les réseaux sociaux
toute l'année dernière inutile de
vraiment se demander pourquoi il suffit
de la regarder un policier dit
maintenant ils disent faisons la
révolution lui-même c'est effectivement
un peu ce que viennent leur demander
le ministre de l'intérieur il a mis le
temps et l'autre répond merde il va
falloir que l'effort que vous le
comprenez comment aba dans dans gb et
puis aussi j'ai trouvé beaucoup l'année
dernière dans le mouvement des chemises
jaunes il ya un parfum de 0,1 c'est à
dire calmement on s'arrête au milieu gb
et de jacques doillon jago lyon est à la
base une bande dessinée qui avait été
publié dans l'hebdo de début des 70 et
est dedans il ya vraiment l'idée de
recommencer à réfléchir sur ce que ce
que peut être la société et c'est quand
même une d une des choses les plus
belles quoi qui a eu dans le mouvement
des idées jaune parmi toutes les beautés
qui a eu il ya eu celle là quand même
quelques il n'ont pas cessé pas
seulement de revendiquer des droits mais
même de revendiquer des devoirs ou de
demander à voir participer à la con à la
construction d'une société qui leur
semblait moins tard et voit juste -
dingue voix
moins pénibles - triste et donc cette
image avait recommencé à circuler
j'étais content aussi de revoir gb dans
cette image de repenser à ce qui était
l'idée de lens 0 1
on arrête tout on réfléchit et c'est pas
triste et bon après c'est aussi
évidemment tout ce qu'il peut y avoir
on pourrait dire de l'articulation entre
comme dans l'islam on a le petit jihad
le grand jihad
on pourrait dire il ya aussi la petite
révolution et la grande révolution donc
la révolution concrètes matériel et puis
la révolution qui est un rapport aussi
au changement complet de soi même et qui
aurait quelque chose aussi de ça qui
serait articulé là il l'entend pas
évidemment comme edouard philippe gb
là-dedans refaisant la révolution nous
mêmes hinterland changer changer notre
rapport au monde
rapport aux autres rapport à la vie ça
s'oppose pas du tout avec une action
politique là dedans ça au contraire ça
la complète
on va rire quand on va parler de votre
livre tout à leur victoire il se trouve
que là pour la première fois depuis je
fais cette émission est totalement par
hasard non mais vous mettant tous les
trois sur un même plateau ça devait
arriver
vous avez choisi des images très
complémentaires il ya encore des la
police chez victor
c'était où c'était quand je crois que
c'était le 1er mai mais bon c'est moi
c'est plus dans plusieurs mines il avait
mal fini le mcdo je crois si c'était le
premier mais ça ce n'est pas mal mais
sinon c'est plus récurrent dans toutes
les manifs je vois ces images alors des
fois c'est les banques à la dernière là
c'était le hilton et il ya souvent ces
images de des crs qui produit et qui
protège les la finance et les autres qui
crèvent la dalle et qui défilent ou pour
regarder les quelques acquis ou pour
voilà il est bon c'est c'est peut-être
un peu manichéen en attendant le choc de
l'image il est il est clair quoi et vous
françois bégaudeau il ya de la police
aussi ouais c'est le fameux croche-patte
la doxa pas très original
alors violences policières tout à fait
dérisoire par rapport aux florilèges que
nous offre la police depuis deux trois
quatre ans est d'ailleurs assez
intéressant que quand il était
interviewé sur la chaîne du service
public récemment
edouard philippe c'est cette image de
violence politique a conduit à montrer
et pas les autres
ouais mais parce que je pense qu'elle
paradoxalement alors qu'elle est
vraiment dérisoire encore une fois elle
dit beaucoup de chose de dur du reste et
notamment l e10 la charge affective qui
a dans la violence policière c'est à
dire que la police a le monopole de la
violence légitime comme on dit et qu'est
ce que ça veut dire le monopole de la
violence légitime quand la loi est elle
même pas légitime
bon ça c'est des gens pour interroger
cette expression mais la police est
fondamentalement violente légitimement
ou pas bon là il ya un élément de
gratuité à propos de toutes violences
policières un flic ou un ministère de
l'intérieur pourra toujours dire qu'il
ya une utilité à la violence policière
disperser et manning des manifestants
parfois les taper un peu brutalement
pour les dissuader le côté dissuasif de
la force bon ça peut toujours se ramener
à une utilité ça pas du tout c'est le
geste de trop c'est le geste
surnuméraires c'est le sait le zèle
policier un peu ludique d'ailleurs de
crushpad ses cours de récré un peu et là
on voit quand même que les policiers
pour être les dépositaires de l'ordre
neutre républicains pour autant dans
sont pas des gens neutres
c'est dire que quand même ce qu'on dit
pas assez par delà les effets de
structure de la police c'est que les
policiers sont des individus et qui sont
constitués idéologiquement or on sait
très bien que notre police française
notamment je sais pas si c'est le cas
exactement dans d'autres polices ça
serait intéressant de l'étudier on sait
que un nombre significatif de flics ont
beau ont voté extrême droite un aux
dernières élections ont voté le
rassemblement national
on en est sûr vraiment à il ya beaucoup
de sondages qui vont dans ceux d'études
un d'études n'ont pas de sondages qui
vont dans ce sens là
bon de toute façon je pense qu'une
constitution majoritairement droitière
des flics français généré je le dis sans
sans même les incriminer c'est un état
de fait
alors c'est quand même intéressant de
voir que bombe à ceux qui sont des
gardiens de l'ordre républicain ne sont
pas neutres comme la république devrait
y est ils sont tout à fait orienté de
logiquement donc ils aiment bien
qu'assez du gauchiste il ya un plaisir
de casser du gauchisme assuré ensuite la
plupart des rangs des crs étaient
étaient occupés par d'anciens paysans
victimes de l'exode rural et qui qu'on
accusait de prendre du plaisir à taper
sur les enfants
la ville où ce qui est tout à fait
possible ce que disait pasolini entre
les crs et les étudiants du côté des crs
a faim on peut aller dans ce genre de
paradoxe intéressant mais là en
l'occurrence je pense que quand même
c'est pas rien d'avoir moi je mets du
coup je m'interroge je pense qu'une
question qu'on peut se dresser des gens
de gauche radicale par exemple qu'est ce
que ça voudrait dire une police de
gauche bien que sachant que dans tout
corps collectif il ya toujours la
nécessité qu'il ya un ordre comme
quelque chose comme de la police pour
assurer la sécurité des uns et des
autres qu'est ce que ça pourrait vouloir
dire une police de gauche je trouve que
c'est un sujet de dissertation hyper
intéressant quand on l'a pas vu sous la
gauche c'est ça aussi parce que non
surtout pas qu'on avait autant de crimes
policiers que je trouve ce qui a changé
c'est quand tu dis gauche et enfin qui
tape un peu sur des gauchistes ne
croche-patte là il est vraiment sale
parce que si on voit après un poteau je
revoyais ce matin si elle somme prend le
poteau c'est méchant mais c'est surtout
moi je pense que c'est ça va beaucoup
plus loin que ce que l'affrontement
casser du gossip cclat avec le mouvement
des gilets jaunes et tout ça a été
vraiment pensé pour moi penser
politiquement pour pour casser le
mouvement pour pour dissuader pour faire
que des gens moi comme ma mère il faut
un début de manifestants après ils sont
bons pour faire que y ait plus de gains
que ça enlève du monde quoi ils fragile
voilà est fondamentalement ça a quand
même marché il ya plein de gens bout
d'un moment qui sont dit bon je vais pas
aller me prendre une grenade je vais pas
aller me faire mutiler voilà et je pense
que ça va plus loin que juste
l'opposition traditionnelle
voilà flics contre bout et ce que je
voulais dire c'est que je pense que ce
flic fait du zèle par rapport à cette
fête de structures qui m'avait frappé 20
secondes c'était dans le land de
premiers entretiens que donne benalla au
nom de l' affaire je passe sur benalla
gros dossiers machin mais il ya un truc
est passé complètement inaperçu si les
deux lignes un moment où ils
caractérisait les manifestants dont il
avait frappé un ou deux ils disaient que
c'étaient des dégénérés ou une phrase
comme ça c'est des dégénérés gauchistes
ont rien dans le cerveau
ce jour-là benalla avait quand même
activer en lui une espèce d'affect de
haine par rapport à tout ce qui
manifeste
c'est pas par delà le ski et ben alla
lui même et ce qu'il incarne par rapport
au pouvoir
donc je pense qu'il ya quand même cette
constitution affective individuelle des
gens qui sont en charge de l'ordre qu'il
faut pas négliger
est-ce que j'ai peur de faire ralentir
les missions mais je voudrais rebondir
ce faux débat sur la police
sur la police avec mais en plus c'est
plus une question qu autre chose mais la
police n'est ce pas justement une
création relativement récente il ya la
modernité et donc du coup une police de
gauche je sais pas si on peut même
penser qu'elle pouvait avoir
elle a pu exister en tant que tel ce que
ça à quoi ça renvoie j'imagine que ça
serait plutôt ces cas là qu'est ce que
serait une chevalerie de gauche même si
le chevalier il ya peut-être une idée
très très old school mais pas forcément
aussi négative que l'idée de police qui
n'est franchement associé qu'à des
actions que toute âme honnête ne peut
que réprouver et pour répondre à la
question qu'est ce que ce serait une
police de gauche et un livre de
sébastian roché que j'ai souvent invité
deux dans cette émission et d'autres
avant et d'ailleurs qu'on entend de plus
en plus sur les autres chaînes parce que
vite depuis qu'on dénonce les violences
policières
c'est un livre qui s'appelle de la
police en démocratie et c'est un peu une
réponse est oui dit effectivement que
beaucoup de police dans d'autres pays
d'europe se sont réformés et pas
tellement en france et il explique
pourquoi
mais commençons
[Musique]
alors françois bégaudeau votre nouvelle
pièce s'intitule piscine avec un s entre
parenthèses elle sera créé le mardi 21
janvier à la comédie de colmar qu'elle
sera en tournée à saint-etienne mulhouse
reims ce une mise en scène de mathieu
crucia ni alors la piscine privée c'est
vraiment l'objet bourgeois de la
modernité on pourrait dire là quelque
chose de rassurant de limpide et en même
temps dès qu'elle est transposée dans un
film on lui trouve immédiatement quelque
chose d'insondable et de et presque 2
d'effrayant que ce soit dans un film
comme la piscine avec alain delon et
fume que tout le monde a vu ou ou dans
un swimmer le film avec burt lancaster
que moins de gens ont vu ou swimming
pool le film de françois ozon et puis
dans les célèbres tableaux de david
hockney où il ya souvent des piscines
comme on va le voir tout de suite il ya
quelque chose d'inquiétant comment vous
l'expliquez est ce que vous y avez pensé
d'abord dès l'instant où vous avez mis
une piscine sur une scène de théâtre là
vous êtes peut-être le premier
d'ailleurs avoir transposé la piscine
privée sur une scène de théâtre
vous saviez bien que l aller nous
inquiéter cette piscine
ouais je vois je pense qu'un fai visuel
mon avis est comme ça je pense qu'on
anticipe aussi beaucoup sur le drame
qu'elle pourrait occasionner puisqu'on
en a vu beaucoup au cinéma des trucs
comme ça va lui alors dans la chronique
des faits divers
machin ce matin-là a été retrouvé par la
femme de ménage noyé dans sa piscine
s'est il suicidé ou entités de bourret
où ou sousse ou des stupéfiants diverses
donc je pense qu'il ya il ya toujours un
crime potentiel dans la piscine ya
toujours l'idée que quelqu'un pourrait
il poussé quelqu'un d'autre quoi et si
vous voyez tout cela si noyé dans la
nuit parce que je pense que ça fait
partie de l'imaginaire collectif on a on
a tous en tête des exemples comme ça
après je pense que le il ya quand même
laisser de l'eau quand même malgré tout
c'est de l'eau domestique et c'est de
l'eau bêtement devient knocké double ou
en général on risque peu de chose quand
même
a priori très peu d'accidents de nage
dans la misère chez les enfants c'est
comme la première cause une des
premières causes de mortalité chez les
très jeunes gens oui voilà c'est vrai
quand même ça donne quand même un passif
aussi accidentelle de l'eau en général
et puis bon c'est quand même une
c'est à chaque fois qu'on voit bien les
enjeux de miroitements aussi je pense
qu'ils créent un truc visuel et donc
perceptif qui crée tout de suite de ma
quiétude il ya quand même l'idée d'une
profondeur même si celle là sur sur le
plateau est pas du tout profonde pour
des raisons techniques met donc à mon
avis les comédiens cinéma rompt pas je
pense qu'il aura pas décideur de
deux plateaux mais quand même il ya un
peu l'idée qu' on va aller on va on va
creuser vers le fond il ya un abîme
possible là dedans donc ce déclic qui a
fait que vous n'êtes ni à écrire une
pièce qui se passait autour d'une
piscine en l'occurrence il se trouve que
le déclic vient surtout du metteur en
scène de mathieu avec qui j'ai beaucoup
travaillé on a on a bossé à chaque fois
le mot n'est pas ma première pièce tout
à fait où on a déjà fait quelques unes
tous les 2es et celle là était vraiment
sur une impulsion thématiques qui était
la sienne il avait comme ça d une
perception de plateau une scénographie
en tête une c'est très blessant six a
produit tout de suite son son effet donc
moi je me suis embarqué dans cet
imaginaire là et j'ai essayé de
réfléchir à ce que pourrait induire
comme scénario comme dramaturgie une
piscine mais évidemment on n'a pas parlé
de la connotation sociale de la piscine
mais qui sur laquelle moi tout de suite
j'ai mis en garde mathieu enfin pas mis
en garde enfin je lui ai dit a objecté
où j'ai fait le con tre points par
rapport à un imaginaire qui serait
justement de pure accolement à une
grande bourgeoisie c'est à côte dans les
années son choix quand même ces
bourgeois et bien de moins en moins
quand même c'est à dire que c'est un
signe extérieur de richesse c'est
évident mais ça c'est extraordinairement
démocratiser quand même dans les années
2000 on va dire la piscine ça reste
toujours un signe de richesse mais c'est
pas la même connotation qui avait par
exemple dans le film the swimmer de
nicole qui venait d'une nouvelle de
cheever où la ces dans les années 60 on
a affaire une grande bourgeoisie qui
s'affiche par la piscine là ça me
permettait via la piscine d'aller parler
d'une ce dont j'avais parlé dans un
essai précédent d'une bourgeoisie plus
ordinaire un plus
quantitativement beaucoup plus répandue
c'est à dire au sens où nous pourrions
tous ici avoir une piscine sans être des
grands milliardaires pas paris mais
ailleurs peut-être oui / logistique sa
résidence jalousie le motif de la pièce
c'est quelqu'un qui plonge dans sa
piscine à une période de sa vie et qui
en ressort à une autre c'est c est ce
que ça en fait pour autant de pièces
fantastique non alors moi j'aime masse
et le fantastique en général quand on
prend dans son sens le plus strict c'est
à dire des légers des règlements du code
réaliste ça c'est vraiment des choses
qui m'intéressent dans la littérature
fantastique dans le cinéma fantastique
qui est toujours et très économe en
effet donc comment dire il ya un tapis
réalise dans cette pièce j'ai même voulu
capter quelque chose de l'époque c'était
quand même un peu ça aussi l'orientation
générale paul qu'est le héros le
personnage principal parle bizarrement
il débarque un peu dans cette
collectivité dont il est d'ailleurs une
émanation il c'est une bande d'amis en
fait c'est sa piscine au des
quadragénaires c'est sa piscine parfois
c'est celle des autres ça dépend de tout
un tas de modulation voilà mais il ay là
il ya des léger décrochage en lui c'est
à dire une chose qui m'intéresse
toujours beaucoup d'ailleurs en écriture
et comme spectateur ou lecteurs c'est
c'est pas la folie qui m'intéresse c'est
la douce folie celle dont on n'est
jamais sûr qu elle ressortie à la folie
ou pas quoi épaules la wii comme ça il a
il a une langue qui est désaxé savent
qu'ils se désaxe légèrement de la
communauté dont il est l'émanation
et alors justement il est il et il est
très soucieux de des différences parfois
un film entre deux mots entre puissance
et pouvoir entre désir et projet dit que
c'est pas la même chose entre image et
métaphore entre le flux et le mouvement
entre une piscine et un bassin pacs
comme c'est par exemple ils assistent
beaucoup sur le fait que là où on l'a ou
s'absente les désirs
on commence à faire des projets oui et
j'ai l'impression que ça aussi ça vous
intéresse beaucoup vous il se trouve que
quand même malgré tout j'ai quand même
écrit ces phrases donc autant ce que je
peux aimer dans le théâtre c'est
d'essayer de parfois de mettre à la
place de personnages qui peut arriver
dans le roman aussi c'est comme ça de
s'oublier soi-même dans des personnages
autant le personnage de paul un moment
comme il a un registre un peu lyrique et
très il est aussi il est un peu donneur
de leçons c'est a dit vivien il vient
faire des grands serments de philosophie
un peu frappadingue assez semblable est
donc là évidemment on fait un retour
dans mon écriture des choses qui peuvent
- d'intéressés donc oui le le désir et
le projet le projet s'est il est arrivé
un drôle de truc à ce mot là parce que
je pense que tous autant qu'on est
depuis il ya encore dix ans le mot
projet nous nous révulse est parce qu on
a des projets et puis est arrivé là
dessus franck lepage le fameux franck
lepage qui donne des conférences
gesticulées compte donc on peut
découvrir sur internet entre autres et
qui nous a mis à quai a mis en évidence
un exemple de la très bonne éducation
populaire
il est que le mot de projet était au
centre du lexique managériale
contemporaine mais aussi ses six tic
puisque aujourd'hui dans la musique de
dragons et beaucoup de gens qui font
plus des groupes wef ont des projets
mais je pense qu'il faudrait qu'il se
méfie quand il parle comme ça parce
qu'il faudrait voir à quel point ils ont
ils ont intériorisé une sorte de langue
officielle du management que moi
d'ailleurs j'ai vu émerger dans
l'éducation nationale un moment vous
avez keystone mais j'ai été prof dans
les années 90 de vide et dès cette
époque là on nous demandait de rédiger
des projets d'établissement donc c'était
il y avait donc là oui le mot projet
d'un seul coup devenu complètement
repoussoir et à quoi je m'oppose
physiquement le désir le désir qu'il
serait peut-être plus singulier le
projet ça serait on se dit bien qu'au
moyen-âge les gens avaient des désirs mu
avait pas de projet ou quoi ben voilà
c'est ça c'est compliqué de se dire que
vous viviez même des héros de la
chevalerie jeu projet c'était le bras
oui voilà payant votre héros il a la
nostalgie des temps sauvage
yves alors quand on vous avait des
désirs et que pas des projets quand on
vivait avec la maladie par exemple il
insiste beaucoup là dessus quand on
n'était pas englué dans le bonheur
climatisé quand on avait encore des
odeurs c'est quand même pas votre cas
vous qu'est ce qui vous intéresse
là-dedans ab ça c'est quand même un truc
qui me travaille beaucoup c'est en fait
on j'ai écrit cette pièce on
j'avais écrit sur une telle bêtise avant
ou j'interpellais le bourgeois comme
comme l'autre par rapport à moi bon même
si des fois je m'associe à moi-même à
l'étiquette bourgeoise mais comme
globalement c'était une interpellation
conflictuelle là j'ai écrit inversement
pas dire en quoi moi je suis dans le
flux est donc s'ils n'ont pas de reçu
oui dans le fût pendant le mouvement
besoin c'est une façon interrogé sur ce
que j'appelle oui le l'imprégnation
générale libérale quoi c'est le modèle
libéral comme un modèle anthropologique
dans lequel nous sommes tous prix on a
beau et antilibérale et contestataire et
pas aimer les flics on est tous à peu
pris et je crois qu'il ya quelque chose
qui nous menace quand même c'est une
espèce de dévitalisation général je ne
veux pas être comme ça prophètes de
mauvais augure mais et c'est vrai que ce
paul d'un seul coup se réveille de 7,2
cette atrophie de cette anesthésie je ne
sais pas comment je suis pas comment les
exactement le dira peut-être de north
asthénie pour dire mais est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas essayer de sauver ce qui
peut encore l'être de notre humanité
primitif sauvage dorade rose éléments 7
dévitalisation dont vous dites c'est ce
qui nous a fait vivre en paix et nous
permet de nager dans des piscines bleus
mais c'est comme ça que j'essaie
vraiment de situer d'écriture la pièce
dans l'ambivalence qu'est la note par
rapport au monde libéral c'est à dire
que pourquoi le monde libéral tient si
longtemps c'est parce que nous en tirons
tous des bénéfices parce qu'il a des
éléments de confort les éléments alors
il ya des grands il ya des grands
perdants de la ferme et même les grands
perdants de la faire le capitalisme a
été suffisamment malin en tout cas dans
les pays occidentaux pour toujours donné
un certain nombre de miettes aux yeux
pour que quand même malgré tout ils se
tiennent à carreau
c'est peut-être en train d'exploser tout
ça et l'équilibré est en train de se
rompre mais quand même et donc je pense
que nous sommes tous quelque part
bénéficiaires du libéralisme et est par
exemple effectivement en termes de
confort peut-être en termes de soins en
termes d hier il ya quelque chose il
nous a pris par la séduction bon paul se
révèle contre ça et dit il est en train
de nous endormir et d'un trend de tout
endormir en moins est ce que alors il
yal après il ya des phrases qui sont
barrées 1
il veut se comparer à une loutre
retrouver l'aisance de la loutre dans
l'eau des rivières et non pas le déficit
s il ya des passages qui est qui est dit
une chose qui moi me fait rire et puis
on est assez réfléchi dîner nous sommes
plus exigeants en amour
s'agissant de l'amour notre général
suire a placé la barre très très haut et
c'est ce qui explique le nombre de
divorces
à votre avis oui je crois que l'on peut
se faire croire qu'au fond on divorce
parce qu'on est plus exigeant que nos
ancêtres
ouais je leur donne de l'amour est là
dessus je peux avoir que des notations
historique un peu approximative enfin il
me semble quand même que finalement
l'amour tel qu'on conçoit nous nous
autres hommes et femmes contemporain est
une idée relativement récent dans les
matières mardi au petit jour que l'idée
d'amour été créé au moyen-âge bockel est
une invention très récente dans
l'histoire d'humanité mais je pense que
tel qu'on l'exigence même d'amour
notamment dans la conjugalité dans la
relation durable
je sais que c'est beaucoup accentué de
sorte que dès qu'il ya un frémissement
de nos amours dans un couple qui s'était
installé dans la durée il ya c'est tout
de suite un cas de divorce est ce que
t'as qu'a su cependant pas dans ces cas
là la mort elle désire justement au fond
c'est que dès que le désir sexuel a
tendance à fléchir que tout à courre dia
puis l'amour mais si je pense que l'un
c'est précisément rabattu sur l'eau
depuis 150 ans on a amalgamé le désir et
la relation durable amoureuse et
événements d'élan qui a pu le désir ça
serait un déni d'amour est donc là
quelque chose qui va pas on est
d'ailleurs il y avait là juste et on a
l'impression que ce qui est dit aussi en
filigrane de cette caisse et un pour
qu'un couple dure il faut l'entretenir
avec des amants et des maîtresses ou
alors il ya les perçages de maîtresse
qui arrive comme ça dans la pièce et qui
ont l'air de dire quelle est leur
existence même qui permet au couple
officiel de durée je pense que c'est un
équilibre qu'on connaît bien notamment
qui est enfin j'veux dire depuis le dix
neuvième depuis bien avant pour tout
dire mais le 19 enfin je veux dire c'est
monsieur qui est un peu las de madame
allaient ils ont compensé sa frustration
sexuelle au bordel de sorte que ça
pouvait cette espèce de négativité qui
était offert par exemple par le bordel
permettait à la norme de se maintenir
c'est quand même un équilibre qu'on
connaît bien quelle équipe patriarcale
on peut l'appeler comme ça
il trouve que paul qui donne un peu des
leçons à tout le monde et qui devrait
réveiller un peu les morts on va se
rendre compte au fil de la pièce qu'en
fait lui vient aussi de cet ancien monde
et que eh ben oui on va découvrir que il
avait cette étude bonne équipe d'avoir
une maîtresse pour l'intensité sexuelle
et le bénin
disons de confort et de sécurité
qu'offre une épouse et que tout allait
bien c'était imparfaite et sa librairie
là c'est assez chez les deux sexes qui
peuvent fonctionner de cette manière là
oui sans doute je pense que quand même
et me semble que c'est équilibre un peu
comme ça binaire maîtresse épouse est
quand même majoritairement investis par
les hommes j'ai quand même encore
l'impression qu'on en est là est ce que
nous vivons une époque sentimentale ça
fait partie des milliers de choses qui
sont dites un moment par ce que
j'appelle le coeur dans cette pièce qui
est une espèce de coeur il ya des gars
des bribes de phrases comme ça qui sont
envoyées qui sont pour moi des inscrits
par par un autre personnage quand il dit
que maintenant on est au courant des cas
une guerre à l'autre bout du monde on
n'a même plus assez de assez de larmes
je crois dit-il nour pour pleurer sur
tout on sait pas grand chose mais ça
suffit pour qu'on se fasse une opinion
qu'on s'indigne etc etc
ça ferait partie de la sentimentalité de
notre époque je crois que là je reprends
je reprends un propos qui est discutable
en soi comme tout ce qui est dit dans
cette pièce parce que voilà les pièces
de théâtre ça sert aussi parfois à
lancer des idées qui sont mises dans la
discussion s'est pas forcément d'aider
des dogmes ou des certitudes que je peux
avoir moi même je le précise parce qu'il
faut pas confondre les deux mais
effectivement le est-ce qu'on pourrait
pas opposée comme ça à titre
hypothétique la sentimentalité et
l'émotion est-ce que c'était ce que ces
deux mots interchangeables ou pas moi il
me semble qu'il ya dans la
sentimentalité qui effectivement a bonne
presse en ce moment enfin je peux dire
qu'il ya une grande sentimentalité moi
je la vois surtout en art je la vois
surtout au cinéma je la vois en
littérature parce que dans la chronique
médiatique pourquoi pas mais qu'elle ait
gagné à ce point-là larissa sam en berne
un peu plus quoi d'ailleurs votre héros
il veut restaurer la cruauté
ouais ça a l'air d'être son fil rouge
ouais ouais ouais il dit ça il dit je
suis venu resterait la cruauté
moi j'aime bien mettre dans la bouche
des personnages des phrases que eux
mêmes ne peuvent pas complètement
comprendre et que moi même je ne
comprends pas donc je ne peux pas
vraiment rendre compte mais cette
affaire de cruauté m'intéresse beaucoup
je dirai ce que ça pourrait être la
cruauté s'est retrouvé quelque chose de
l'ordre de la sauvagerie
ouais mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire la
sauvage qui fait qu'on est fasciné par
les serial killers peut-être je pense
quoi je pense qu'il ya une espèce de
de refoulement du sauvage qui ressort
notamment à travers la chronique des
faits divers qui moi me fascine comme
elle fascine tout un tas de gens je veux
dire j'ai donc après il faut pas oublier
quand même le grand bénéfice de confort
effectivement de pacification de nos
sociétés modernes
donc c'est compliqué cette ambivalence
entre ça sur moi même je suis très
partagé en un personnage qui dit ça
d'ailleurs un acquis qui rêvasse autour
de ça qu'ils disent est quand même là il
ya la médecine contemporaine par exemple
nous a très largement débarrasser de la
douleur de douleur qui était absolument
m'est insupportable jusqu'à très
récemment dans l'histoire de l'humanité
donc il ya quand même énormément de
bénéfices de ce personnage dit que
c'était mieux qu'entre vivre et que sa
mère est dit en tout cas ce qu'on peut
poser c'est que la maladie fait partie
du vivant et que donc vouloir amputer le
vivant de la maladie c'est vouloir
computer les vivants lui-même donc paul
arrive avec ces espèces d'options comme
ça presque nietzschéenne excès de
ressaisir le vivant dans sa totalité y
compris dans sa brutalité sa cruauté sa
sauvagerie on y reviendra avec pacôme
thiellement qui est peut-être chose à
dire là dessus et qu'il dira d'ailleurs
quand on parlera de solides
je rappelle que la pièce est écrit à la
comédie de colmar mardi 21 janvier elle
est six jours jusqu'au 29 30
oui et ensuite elle part en tournée
saint-etienne mulhouse notamment rens
rien de prévu à paris l'an prochain l'an
prochain elle s'intitule piscine on fait
une pause on se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode de ses
cages consacré cette semaine à vos
prévisions olivier quand je fais des
scénarios je le souhaite pas forcément
on a toujours ce problème avec la chine
qui essaie de lutter contre l'hégémonie
américaine
assez paradoxalement je pense que la
chine est plus dangereux que l'iran je
pense qu'on a un pays qui est aux abois
vous savez quand les guerres se
déclenchent elles se déclenche toujours
parce que les gens ils y ont intérêt à
être 4e prévisions à lebrac cité un
éclatement de la zone euro non moi je
crois pas du tout à un éclatement de la
zone euro et j'attends même avec une
certaine impatience l'entrée de l'ecosse
dans la zone euro alors je ne sais pas
si les causes va rétablir la frontière
est embêté la reine d'angleterre mais en
revanche l'union européenne va avoir
quelques soucis en 2020 oui c'est bien
dit la crise est derrière nous ah ouais
donc la crise de l'euro est derrière
nous donc le fmi je sais que pour
olivier si ça va faire vibrer
[Musique]
à
mais
[Musique]
à quels types d'élèves s'adresse cette
nouvelle proposition éducative les
enfants que nous allons recevoir nous au
cours des frères montgolfier sont ceux
qui n'ont pas atteint le seuil qui leur
permet d'être reconnu
ces élèves sont des élèves finalement on
a soupçonné qui s'était dyspraxiques
dyslexique enfants intellectuellement
précoces nous travaillons et c'est là
notre réussite
non pas qu'ils aient un examen mais
qu'ils aient la capacité de revenir
d'une manière très confortable sur le
terrain classique tant qu'on n'aura pas
compris que nous avons nous sommes en
train de vivre un énorme tournant et un
énorme bouleversement de la pratique
d'être professeur aujourd'hui et demain
nous aurons un mal être
une somme à train de former les adultes
de demain il faut comprendre que la
france de nos banlieues et la france et
qu'il faut l'a formé et qu'il ne désire
que cela
[Musique]
mes invités sont aujourd'hui françois
bégaudeau pour sa nouvelle pièce piscine
est actuellement pour son nouveau livre
tu m'as donné de la crasse et j'en ai
fait de l'or et victor du groupe victor
and the hunters qui sort un premier
album blackout
on va sans écouter tout de suite un
extrait avec le clip trash et l'époque
victor and the writers alors les kits on
a des boues stupide et dérape à 6
pistons écoutant victimes at eu les
reins solides as tu pris d assaut
propager gossip mais pense à la paie
aussi les équipes sans éthique ça
pullule dans la triche c'est vers ath au
régime aidera 100% biture et saut à
l'élastique faut une des trappistes et
j'ai retrouvé ton à ce type en plus
canal si donald j en argile se moduler
son rôle au gré des tendances de la
ville niveau flausch valide ya des
gosses qui taquine mais les stars en
vitrine un batteur qui s'appuie me tue
les poétesses elle
les secteurs les lumières du dessert ils
tendent entre défaire tout le poids de
mes verres pour un trip a lâché j'ai
deux verts ont fait valser l'école on
m'a craché l'époque faut faire des
coptes a pas mesuré le poids de ma
colère est l'addition de metok du salon
de la treille [ __ ] si nerveux cuit et
j'adorais d île de man durable tu veux
du viril et bateaux a dû que jamais la
roma 2
[Musique]
sors plus
devant
[Musique]
jamais là
du coup on
jamais
de rang
and so glad devant mes semblables se
faire bouillir le bois sont rués dans
les rades le peuple et massot le temps
est maussade en marche et le marquis de
sade entre nous de douleur douleur
encore plus de dollars sur le seul à
rêver d'un bolloré d'un col à violetta
les pires de noto là à merde je suis
abonné à canal j'vais pas m'exiler en
camargue n'y aura pas de brasles connu
de cavale l'ultra gauche peut lancer sa
cabale va dire aux petits de ne pas bibi
les baloches son plein à faire olivier
le nouveau monarque n'a pas besoin
d'aller vie le crime parfait c'est
bosser pour les lobbys et tour didon au
gourbi
les langues se sont engourdis je sais
pas c'était mieux avant je sais que
c'est dégueulasse aujourd'hui demain ils
forment un livre de calais focale et
fait même langue qui se glisse dans le
cul du medef de malice en malaise des
balaises qui pâlissent de ville qui
balaie qui tamise qui va doubler sa mise
quitte à bize je tape des allocs et me
bloch à la crise en reste et légaux
rivière ni de gauche ni de droite
voudrait modéré prêt à coopérer et non
les sens et rester le cul dans la boue
et un coude sur le syndrome raison des
chiens mail
oran
[Musique]
de rang
plus
[Musique]
jamais là
tant du coup
en plus
jamais
roma 2
victor vous dites je sais pas si c'était
bien avant je sais que c'est dégueulasse
aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression que
beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui qui disent
que c'est dégueulasse aujourd'hui au
fond est vite d'expliciter parce que
vous êtes tout le monde est d'accord
mais bon c'est les gens sont d'accord
pour les membres que c'est dégueulasse
pour les mêmes raisons non je pense pas
chacun sa notion du dégueulasse mais
c'était aussi un parallèle parce que
c'est une phrase de de vieux cons chez
pas mais en tout cas de nostalgiques
qu'on entend aussi beaucoup dans le rap
à dire que l'arabe était mieux avant
enfin il ya ça dans tous les courants de
la littérature aussi c'est toujours
c'est toujours mieux avant mais après il
ya le constat d'époque et comme le
morceau s'appelle trachée l'époque c'est
vrai qu'à un moment si on est juste
lucide
cc c'est juste dégueulasse tout ce qu'on
doit tous les jours donc c'est dur de
dire autre chose quoi justement moi je
me pose toujours cette question je me
dis mais quand on trouve ça dégueulasse
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que ça devait être
avant c'était encore pire
voilà donc oui vous êtes d'ailleurs j'ai
la rage de mes 20 ans moi le balai dans
le cul vous aviez vraiment qu'il ya un
petit balai un petit ballet qui me non
mais je viens moi je viens du on va dire
du rap qu'on appelait conscient engagé
pure et dure politique comme ça et qu'il
y avait une posture
enfin il fallait aller se la raconter un
peu fallait enfin voilà fallait avoir
des êtres intelligents fallait être
sérieux tout ça quoi à un stage l'âge
est un peu là dedans puis avait le côté
hip hop beaucoup de vous le balai dans
le cul ça en gros la posture quoi c'est
pas tant d'être qui s'appelait qu'à la
chasse à ces époques qui a fait
plusieurs albums et un moment je crois
que vous l'avez dit vous avez découvert
le rock
bah ouais j'y suis venu tard j'étais
complètement dans ce balai dans le cul y
avait aussi plein de préjugés et plein
de plans de bêtises et d'inculture et
notamment il y avait zéro ouverture sur
sur le roc et j'ai avancé par étapes en
fait via le sampling d'aller chercher
dédié j'ai découvert le jazz après la
soul la funk et je suis venu tardivement
disent on va dire vers 25 ans j'ai
commencé à découvrir les beatles pour
dire que le maroc et par étapes des
beatles au claj des clashs et ainsi de
suite et après j'ai plus j'ai pu
décrocher et quand vous faites du rap
électro punk ouais je pense ou du punk
rap ou mais c'est vrai que maintenant le
pour les rappeurs on est des punchs
voulait pas qu'on reste des rappeurs
donc vous ne rappelais plus vous scandé
sa dépendent et y est il ya des titres
qui sont vraiment scandé il y en a
d'autres qui sont clairement rap et ça
je m'amuse avec les délais de débit des
fois c'est crier des fois c'est râpé
c'est pas trop chanter c'est tout vous
dites dans ce morceau le peuple est maso
ben ouais parce que par moment bon là je
trouve que quand même c'est des paroles
on va dire proto gilet jaune mais mais
cette phrase là lé proto gilet jaune
c'est à dire qu'à un moment où vraiment
on était d'en parler de la neurasthénie
cta leur j'avais vraiment l'impression
qu'on était dans une époque
voilà sans aucune réaction avec ben on
bouffe de la merde et on est content et
je trouve qu'à cannes depuis ban avec
les gilets jaunes mais pas que il ya ça
se réveille de partout en ce moment
c'est assez super là dessus et donc
cette phrase est peut-être un peu moins
juste aujourd'hui qu'elle l'était il ya
qu'elle l'était il ya deux ans mais est
globalement si quand même on parlait du
libéralisme tout à l'heure est plein de
choses qu'on nous plein de systèmes
comme libéralisation par exemple dans
lequel on se met à fond alors qu'on sait
que ça va tout défoncé mais on dit allez
on y va c'est génial il ya des
trottinettes il ya du hub et ritz il ya
des conneries comme ça et donc en ce
sens là on a un peu maso dès qu'on nous
donne un truc on fonce sans regarder les
servitudes volontaires dont parlait de
la boétie assez longtemps dois être
l'autre on en serait pas sorti pense pas
qu'on soit sorti depuis un an la plus
que non bien sûr est évident que si le
crime parfait c'est de bosser pour les
le bee ware web à ccc non mais c'est le
côté heures invisible violence enfin
violence discrète où on laisse les
autres faire le taf et puis on a moins
cette image on va dire réactionnaire
frontale ou c'est un peu le truc de tous
et néolibéraux et tout ça quoi qu'il
arrive avec un qui arrive à te la faire
on est cool alors que c'est des ordures
mais il avance ou un petit tapis et puis
règlent leur histoire par dessous quoi
j'ai cette impression là on va regarder
un autre extrait de cet album c'est ici
ça brûle barcares dont le clip
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis lucide et parle dans la journée
annuelle de détox n'oserait pas elle me
le rend bien mal mes rêves à coups de
madame négoce avec des larbins ferreux
sont en marche au pas ou on accepte la
marge la même veine de losers qui rêvent
des marges et aucun flic pour la france
deux marchés il m'a plu mais dopé au rad
de quartier seront pas laisser les
palaces à tous ces cadavres qui cravache
dans l'axial au chalut m
mieux
marc roger
épicer la mas vieux j'suis un d'éviter
mes carnets de carnage aucune siècle
ça car mes moyens je me dis partout
crasse de mes droits
tron
la food drug vers le banc des creux ça
c'est vraiment ça coûte
de voir les pieds nickelés mars et qui a
ses soucis avec mes free collage
sur les locales pour m'occuper des docks
lui
véritable avant
je suis au bout
perché on plane deux ego tout la lunette
qui moi qui connaît une phase pour le
danger aux gars au chiotte la brûler les
conventions
on dit emma en date expire en mai
girlz de bondy mon père m'a appris
comment percer bien droit si fort est
d'abord
archives
mouffetard sc vendredi souplesse star s
et vendredi j'ai un truc est la patrie
je le dis en noir et
20th dans la partie rediffuse le bordel
sa perte et demandions vient bien sûr
que ça compte mais la classe et surtout
dans la trajectoire la vie en ligne
droite berck l'amour du zig zag g une
descente aux flambeaux comme répertoire
ici ça brûle
ici sans voix
[Musique]
le rock a été une musique très
contestataire l'europe
ensuite a pris le relais devenu à son
tour la musique contestataire d'une
époque et ça fait bien 25 ans que ça
dure maintenant même plus leurs apps et
les années 80 c'était les mêmes juste
avant vous j'ai l'impression alors avec
le rap électro punk que vous reprenez un
peu tout ça mais la façon de l'exprimer
vocalement c'est plutôt très français
c'est à dire que c'est ni rock ni rap
profond j'ai l'impression que c'est ce
qu'on dit dans les bistrots on commence
à quand on commence à s'échauffer
au niveau de la langue ouais c'est tout
à fait vrai sur les bistrots saab qui
passe beaucoup trop de temps et ça ça
influence pas mal ma langue
après très français je sais pas parce
que je suis pas un bizarrement bon
j'adore la langue française dans les
romans dans l'écriture et tout ça mais
apprendre musique j'écoute très très peu
de musique française donc après 6,6
assez ça sonne français pour vous tant
mieux moi je mais je peux je peux pas me
raccrocher à quelque chose en terme
d'esthétique française on va dire que
j'ai lu quelque part que vous étiez
enfant chez vous des côtés du léo ferré
ouais par contre en et j'en ai bouffé
par sa ressort peut-être mais ils
scandaient aussi marronne c'était ferré
brassens brel en boucle foulon ferrer
particulièrement monde est dingue quoi
j'ai appris à l'époque il me saouler
parce qu'il y avait ce truc de fin de
vie ce camp des oui non plus des grandes
envolées fin c'était le côté
grandiloquent
voilà ça ça me ça me rendait fou mais
après j'ai appris j'ai appris à
apprécier notamment avec quand il est
allé avec ce groupe de rock prog zhu zhu
ça j'ai bien aimé il ya des trucs des
superbes chansons quoi il faisait de la
pop
à une époque où les français ça fait pas
du tout faire de la musique ouais c'est
peut-être et non j'y vois aussi je pense
au bistrot parce que au fond je trouve
que les français nous ont fait la
révolution au bistrot c'est toujours
l'accès mais j'ai l'impression dans la
dans le
il faut le verbaliser mais c'est
toujours dans les bistrots qu'on
commence par le verbaliser les gens tant
chez vous quelque chose qui ressemble
plus à ça chez les anglo saxons ça se
passe pas comme ça quoi qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
pacôme thiellement si la révolution se
passe moins dans les histoires en
angleterre mais ils sont beaucoup dans
les pubs et ils sont beaucoup mieux
quand même
ils sont beaucoup dans les plaines mais
je trouve qu'il ya quelque chose de
typiquement français là dedans a dans le
dans le rap le rapport au bistrot comme
lieu de rue de vern la lisait sur leurs
dépenses et même de lui dépend si tout à
fait je crois qu'il ya un autre sa bague
au doigt que la politique en tout cas
d'émancipation et n'est là où des gens
peuvent se rassembler et en france c'est
vrai que le bistrot est un des lieux où
on peut se rassembler par exemple le
soir on peut trouver des gens là vous
allez mosquée oui voilà travail a dit à
d'autres lieux qui sont par exemple les
lieux de travail
un lieu de travail c'est un lieu où les
gens se rassemblent et ça peut ça peut
se basculer en grève ça peut basculer en
contestation sachant que le capitalisme
a été suffisamment malins pour
disséminer les lieux de travail et donc
empêcher cette agrégation
je pense qu'il ya un autre lieu
d'agrégation possible ou de de coalition
des gens c'est internet
on sait je pense pas les gilets jaunes
on sait bien que quand même la part de
facebook tout ça dans la l'émergence du
mouvement était vachement important quoi
alors après qu'est ce qu'on peut penser
de cette coagulation la part internet
qu'elle qu'elle affecte politique elle
produit moi c'est vraiment une question
je ne pousse jamais le produit d et e
vous allez de guerre et votre groupe
mais chut et aux les ce qui est évident
c'est qu'il est est ce qu'ils seront sur
scène avec vous oui oui à bagnolet à la
belle maison
le y en aura une partie sur scène avec
moi c'est une nébuleuse que ce soit les
gens en studio ce soit les gens de scène
mais c'est vrai que sur scène mort ce
moment c'est mettre match et otchakovsky
qui seront avec moi banyoles les
formules des fois peuvent tourner mais
vraiment c'était notamment mokhtar
montdidier de l'époque et fois tous les
gens qui sont suivis dans ce projet ont
quand même tendance à trouver tout le
reste de la musique notamment françaises
nul à chier
je suis peut-être des fois le plus
coulants mais je commence à rentrer
aussi dans ce truc quoi et donc à ford
ont tous des gens critiquer tout le
temps je me suis dit bon bar est un peu
loin quoi saleh a été enlevée le
parallèle avec cette époque internet ou
des gens vous font énormément de vue
parce qu'ils se font en fait dégueuler
dessus de leur cerveau et vice versa et
pas deux voilà ces deux camps même nom
de victor and the red shoes l'album
s'intitule blacks
out récemment c'était blacklist neuf
c'est black out et bistrots et vous
serez vous sera en concert la belle
maison à bagnolet samedi prochain
[Musique]
comme tellement c'est maintenant votre
tour votre nouveau livre s'intitule tu
m'as donné de la crasse j'en ai fait de
l'or ça vient de paraître chez masse aux
éditions c'est une phrase de baudelaire
au départ qu'ils avaient été tournées à
lui s'adressait à paris où il parlait de
la boue taf et il avait fait de l'or
vous c'est de la crasse en fait
l'histoire c'est qu'au départ cette
phrase-là les sorties j'écrivais un
petit texte sur les bouddhas b du niger
ou d'abaisser une tribu du niger
magnifique qui chaque année font une
grande procession où ils sont maquillés
les hommes les hommes se maquille en
fait et c'est en procession amoureuse où
les femmes regardent les hommes tous
maquiller faire une sorte de procession
de beauté et toute l'année en fait ils
font ça ils sont signés les tribus les
plus pauvres ils font ça avec des
détritus prennent des détritus et ils
s'en font du maquillage ça et comme j'ai
tendance à citer sans vérifier parce que
c'est au fil de la plume chez gémissant
dire baudelaire d'ailleurs mais genre
c'est baudelaire tu m'as donné de la
crasse et j'en ai fait de l'ordre dans
le corps du texte
et puis après le temps venu on vérifiait
merde c'était tu m'as donné ta bouche en
effet de l'or et puis cette phrase étant
devenu pour moi un talisman enfin
comment dire c'était quelque chose que
je sais pas j'ai pas cessé de me dire
aussi pour moi-même affrontant des
événements de pénibles des événements
pénibles du quotidien vous avez vraiment
pénible
de la psyché bizarre qu'un peu quel être
humain peut avoir c'était vas-y donne
moi la crasse phase i est donc bon le
titre est resté détourné alors ça
commence au japon en 2002 'vraie vie' 27
ans vous étiez avec votre petite amie
japonaise et vous avez soudain
l'impression très douloureuse d'ailleurs
que vous allez devenir un tueur de stars
comme mark david chapman
l'homme qui a assassiné john lennon
après l'avoir adoré et vous avez
l'impression vous allez devenir comme ça
oui
en fait c'est le sait le ouais c'est le
premier première chapitre du livre par
sur un des trucs les plus terribles que
j'ai vécu en fait
mentalement c'est cette impression là
c'est vraiment comique quand je j'y
repense ça c'est vraiment fou parce qu
en fait j'étais au japon joue avec des
choses magnifiques nara les temples de
nahr al temple avec les tigres
celui avec les biches en liberté kyoto
les jardins zen tout ça était sublime
puis progressivement j'étais un peu
second j'étais aussi avec des gens qui
parlaient tous japonais j'étais avec ma
petite amie qui parle avec japonais avec
eux et on était chez certains d'entre
eux la télé était allumée et là il ya un
présentateur de télévision japonaise
s'appelle depuis j'ai fait j'ai fait des
recherches pour être vraiment précis
mazak et sa kawasaki sakai qui présente
l'émission chabada ce trio qui est qui
est une émission de nourriture là à mon
souvenir en plus des pâtes aux oeufs et
je vois et je dis mon dieu je vais tuer
cet homme
je sais que je vais tuer cet homme et
j'ai vécu tout le reste de mon voyage au
japon avec cette certitude que non
seulement je vais le tuer mais que les
éléments qui allait m'amener à cet état
de fait que ça va être ça mais c'était
ça mon grand destin au grand espoir
d'avoir un destin car on avait on veut
tous avoir une quelque chose qui fasse
notre vie quoi quelque chose qui est ce
serait ça et après c'est en
déconstruisant j'ai compris est en fait
en déconstruisant la vérité c'est que ce
moment là j'avais eu mon premier livre
qui était sur le mythe de la mort de
paul mccartney mais qui contenait aussi
des étapes sur charles manson et sur
mark david chapman et sur l'histoire en
fait l'histoire terrible avec les
beatles
ce qui est sa plus produire aussi des
deux phénomènes affreux et donc j'avais
étudié la vie de chacun je pensais plus
à ce moment-là mais j'avais étudié et
j'avais donné ce livre j'ai fait un
petit éditeur à l'époque il n'avait pas
beaucoup de moyens et il a attendu très
longtemps avant de sortir donc c'est ce
que vous d'un an et demi j'avais pas de
nouvelles et compagnie est en fait en
gros c'était la crainte que nous sommes
au dos j'avais jamais arriver à tout
petit microscopique stupide espoir que
les petites histoires de john lennon
d'ailleurs face b pas évidemment tank
horizon genre formidable c'est lennon
c'est juste sortir mon petit bouquin
j'ai découpé de manta ray et je me suis
dit enfin j'ai analysé comme ça c'est à
dire qu'en gros le monde ce qui là
terrible pour ça qu'il ya quelque chose
moi c'est comment dire il ya un truc
d'injustice fondamentale qui est
irréparable
c'est quel que soit le statut qu'on a
dans la société ce truc il est réparable
c'est que par exemple dans ce monde il y
ait des john lennon mark david chapman
il ya plus de mark david chapman que de
john lennon grand gros il ya plus de
fans que de stars par exemple et qu'on
est tous un peu des barques david qui a
bien sûr et c'est ça que j'ai vraiment
expérimenté alors pas sur une figure
glorieuses comme john lennon sur un
pauvre présentateur psy japonaise qui
n'avait rien fait ce que je veux être
dans ce livre c'est qu'au fond parce que
vous l'avez résolu depuis plus largement
oui le problème c'est que notre malheur
ne nous est pas propre et une partie
d'après vous d'un d'une sorte de grand
des freins aux rousses et la crasse dont
vous parlez dans le titre alors comment
avez vous fait pour le changer ça en or
justement c'est que c'est un homme il ya
un grand destin un dessein qui fait
qu'on est tous malheureux quoi oui la
villa bon nous rendre malheureux c'est
en tout cas la conclusion à laquelle
vous êtes arrivé cette voie de départ
mais oui mais le truc c'est que la vie
va pas nous faire de cadeau quand bien
même on croit que là ça y est elles truc
tout il ya la chose à côté qui va être
le machin c'est le truc qu'on voit même
sur les gens qui ont réussi entre
guillemets ou qui pensent qu'ils ont
réussi qui sont tellement malheureux ils
sont tellement dans une espèce de
désarroi et des spas comprennent
absolument pas que en fait ce qu'il
disait était complètement en décalage
par rapport à véritablement les
conditions possibles delà de leur
réalisation de leur épanouissement de la
réalisation fait de se sentir bien en
tant qu'homme fait sentir juste en tant
qu'homme d'être ce que dedans j'utilise
le terme juste conduite de villejust
conduite de vie prouver la bonne
conduite de vie quelque chose qui fait
que l'on se sent pas dégueulasse quoi et
ça c'est en fait c'est ça le on va dire
le truc qui est le projet fera reprendre
les termes de plaisir
le personnage de la pièce de lego d'eau
est exactement dans cette situation là
dans ce mélange justement de bonheur et
de malheur nouveau totalement ensemble
et
et donc c'est le truc qui est le machin
que j'essaie de travailler dans le livre
s'est étalée sur un bon nombre d'enfants
c'est long à écrire c'était au départ
c'était un projet qui va serrer les vis
en fait
et puis c'est en gros c'est à la fois un
essai c'est le vin à l'issue de ma vie
c'est à la fois et comment je n'en
sortais pas mort comme je suis encore
vivant et et c'est à chaque fois essayé
de prendre les endroits où je pense que
j'étais le plus nul les agressions ou
des trucs les plus terribles où sont
arrivés parfois par l'extérieur parfois
par ma faute parfois par machin et les
dents fall et les machins on a
l'impression qu'on va pas pouvoir se
relever et à quel point en fait il était
plus riche d'enseignements et une plus
grande matière en fait pour de
connaissances et à dire que si on
associe on va dire le bonheur avec une
idée liée à la connaissance le malheur
est une matière fabuleuse et c'est là
aussi où ça devient alchimique c'est là
où ça devient on va dire chinois c'est à
dire un truc un peu chinois de stratégie
chinoise où on va on va on va utiliser
les faiblesses comme force et où les
forces vont se révéler des faiblesses et
c est là aussi mon pays on essaie
d'articuler en difficulté à la fois on
va dire le son petit cas personnel et
l'homme dans le sens où si on prend sa
vie toute vie en fait je m'étais dit
qu'acheter des crises je t'ai dit je
veux l'écrire comme si je pouvais
recevoir le récit de ma voisine du
dessus que j'aimerais savoir ça sur elle
j'aimerais qu'elle raconte en gros pas
son récit glorieux parlera quand j'ai
rencontré mon mari mange pas quoi mais
les trucs pénible qu'elle a affrontée et
qu'est ce qu'elle en a retiré et donc
c'était parce que toute vie est une
interprétation de la vie la vie le truc
l'autre on a tous et chaque vie on peut
considérer que chaque vie est le
l'interprétation chaque humain a fait de
ce groupe général sur la vie mais tout
me dit aussi que tout toute une vie ne
suffirait pas à apprendre à vivre
alors en fait j'ai l'impression que vous
avez toujours cherché comment accélérer
le processus d'apprentissage et comment
s'initier au fond et si vous avez lu le
grand intérêt que vous portez au cno
stick ce que vous appelez les sans
droits
vous cherchez à être initiés au fond
comment faire pour que pour progresser
dans ce labyrinthe du malheur qu'est la
vie où j'ai cherché mon premier les
premiers docteurs c'est l'épaule est
beaucoup de gens c'est demander à nerval
rimbaud baudelaire on va demander à
alfred jarry le tram on verra ça peut
être les jambes de la dure du rock de la
pop ou un écrivain de science-fiction
comme philip k.dick ce que j'ai fait
kddi qui m'avait semblé c'est là où vous
faites ou servant à la jonction de tout
ça que j'ai rencontré la pensée
gnostique moustique est ce que ce qui
nous pose des problèmes en gros c'est de
dire oui à ce que ce monde avait d'
intolérable je trouve et le monde en
tant qu entité cosmique intolérable dans
la répartition des malheurs qui
produisent et dans le ps de logique
implacable du malheur et l'espèce de
trucs pour ça ça marche le malheur ça
marche à tous les coups
et donc là dans la spiritualité j'ai
préféré de tam sans roi fut tel que
jésus leur donne comme il y avait de
toute façon cette défiance intégral par
rapport à la fois la hiérarchie foi au
dieu seigneur qui seraient supposés les
bonbons etc etc il y avait l'idée de 2
d'arriver à utiliser la matière noire de
7,2 cette réalité pour produire autre
chose avec c'est ce qu'on arrive à en
faire qui peut arriver à transformer sa
et à travers eux à travers dit qu à
travers eux et il ya l'exégèse est
arrivée la question l'exégèse élections
d'exégèse comme mettons le la façon dont
on arrive à travers une matière à la
fois la reconduire à soi à la reprendre
au monde et à la halle à faire résonner
à la fois un niveau personnel à un
niveau politique
un niveau métaphysique mais ton arrivée
à trouver le système de résonance qui
permettra d'avoir une vie à peu près à
peu près cohérente et à peu près de
descente
la preuve pour vous que notre monde est
à denfert pacôme thiellement c'est parce
qu'un livre ou un film coûte moins cher
car sandwich non mais ça ça fait partie
du truc
oui il ya plein de choses que je trouve
qu'ils montrent qu'il ya des règlements
complets et en tout cas
rapport à va dire économique de l'époque
et il est tard et c'est avec un livre
soit si peu cher par rapport à la
nourriture
c'est pourquoi ce qu'il voudrait
évidemment que les gens puissent avoir
d'abord c'est d'abord c'est un thouars
le truc le plus cher c'est le logement
mais c'est un truc de fou
ça devrait être la base on devrait
l'avoir ça on devrait pouvoir avoir un
toit pour voir vivre et c'est vrai que
la base c'est complètement con que les
offres complètes d'hitchcock ça coûte si
peu cher parce que le clochard qui s'en
[ __ ] des oeuvres complètes d'hitchcock
c'est c'est ce truc doit être à l'envers
et pour moi surtout que c'était même pas
un cadeau fait à l'art que ce soit si
peu cher par rapport au reste c'est une
aberration dire c'est pas parce que tu
ton livre les gens pour l'acheter à 6
euros qui là qu'il aura plus de valeur
là vous comprenez bien pourquoi c'est
que si je vous donne à ce texte et que
vous le manger je ne l'est plus et vous
non plus oui si je voudrais manger le ce
texte donne un livre ou un film
aujourd'hui par les méthodes oui une
technologie que dont nous disposons non
seulement je n'ai encore will et ça ne
coûte rien à vous de vous en faire une
copie de vous le donner alors ça c'est
aussi pour ça que c'est moins cher qu'à
sandwich ça je comprends très bien dans
le partage c'est tout à fait différent
le partage de finir le jeu mais
complètement à côté la politique
culturelle
on va dire en tout cas du du fait que la
culture l'art ça soit si accessible
alors que les fondamentaux qui fait que
quelqu'un puisse simplement décemment
vivre soit si inaccessible cc c'est là
le truc à l'envers le logement est le
plus cher est plus difficile c'est une
logique pourrait presque avoir presque
tout mais pas de toi c'est affreux merci
tous les trois d'avoir participé à cette
émission tuba deuil de la crasse et j'en
ai fait de l'or de pacôme thiellement
sécher masse aux éditions piscine la
nouvelle pièce de françois bégaudeau
sera créé du 21 au 30 janvier à la
comédie de colmar dans une mise en scène
de mathieu crucia ni elle partira
ensuite en tournée jusqu'à fin mai dijon
saint-etienne mulhouse et race enfin
l'album de victor and the fighters
s'intitule black out et le groupe sera
en concert à la belle maison à bagnolet
samedi prochain merci de nous avoir
suivis rendez-vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]